Please control your anger They will allow you to kill them here Do
n't you feel anything when you see those two
? Did you order me to control your anger?
It's like this because you
talk nonsense to
me Don't interrupt me I'm a tiger Watching a video
Because I can't,
if you die, because I'm by your
side
[music] A
world day
without you With a defense that you've stopped coming
to tell me what to wait For a
long time without an existence yet,
I'm weak, I can't stand
[music]  [Music]
I'm weak, I'm weak I was just strong
in front of your Emilia
[Music] Hey,
you ignored my existence for a long time On the contrary, it's exciting, isn't it
?  That's what I'm saying, you'll die tomorrow around the same time
dai
Let's forgive everything, whether it's living with you or your abusive
language The purpose of bringing you here has already been achieved It's fine for you to go home now I
'm satisfied with bringing you here, so I'm going home now  Then
, on my part
, Kyouka can't be here
.  you can talk slowly